bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la
faq 400 mille abonnés et je suis très
heureux que cette faq et lieu
aujourd'hui c'est à dire au moment de la
rentrée parce que ça va me permettre de
faire un petit point sur les moments
forts de l'année passée et également de
vous informer des projets pour l'année
qui vient alors on commence à répondre à
vos questions et elles ont été
nombreuses et vous avez été
particulièrement inspiré je vais
commencer par faire quelques annonces
rapides la première chose c'est que je
vous invite à me rejoindre en masse sur
instagram c'est le réseau social sur
lequel je serai le plus actif cette
année je ne suis pas un utilisateur
forcené des réseaux sociaux mais si vous
voulez être tenu au courant de mon
actualité
si vous voulez savoir quels seront les
thèmes de mai prochain épisode eh bien
je ne peux que vous encourager à vous
abonner à ma page instagram deuxième
annonce pour ceux qui l'ignoreraient
encore je vous invite à me rejoindre sur
ma page pas très jeunes patriotes c'est
un site qui vous permet de rémunérer vos
créateurs de contenu vos artistes
préférés et contrairement à tipi
patronne ce n'est pas simplement un site
qui vous permet de faire un don à votre
créateur c'est surtout un site qui vous
permet de bénéficier de son contenu
exclusif de son contenu inédit et il se
trouve que sur ma page patronne je fais
au minimum deux publications par semaine
publication qui peut être soit lié à mon
actualité aux coulisses de mon travail
mais j'y publie aussi des épisodes
inédits par exemple les capsules concept
qui sont des épisodes en format court
que je propose sur ma page patronne et
dans lesquels je vais développer je vais
expliciter le sens d'un concept
philosophique
je propose également les épisodes retour
dans lesquels je reviens sur le dernier
épisode que j'ai publié sur ma chaîne et
donc pour toutes ces raisons si vous
souhaitez me soutenir si vous souhaitez
encourager à poursuivre mon travail eh
bien je ne peux que vous inviter à me
rejoindre sur la page patriotes et enfin
dernière annonce qui va je pense réjouir
un grand nombre d'entre vous c'est qu'à
partir du mois d'octobre du 14 octobre
pour être précis je lance les cours
collectifs en visioconférence ça faisait
longtemps qu'une grande partie d'entre
vous me demandez de proposer des cours
de philosophie ans visio et bien à
partir du mois d'octobre ce sera
désormais possible et donc si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur les cours de
philosophie que je vais proposer je vous
invite à aller consulter mon site
internet
www.la tirer précepteur point fr parce
que c'est là que j'annoncerai au fur et
à mesure les thématiques des cours de
philosophie que je propose est donc si
le thème du cours vous intéresse et que
vous avez envie d'y participer eh bien
il vous suffira de cliquer sur le bouton
s'inscrire aux cours de suivre la
procédure d'inscription et vous recevrez
un mail qui contiendra toutes les
informations j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour signaler que si vous vous inscrivez
via pas très jeune vous pourrez
bénéficier en plus du cours de tous les
avantages que je propose sur cette page
patriotes donc je vous mets tous les
liens dans la description je vous laisse
regarder ça et je vous annonce d'ores et
déjà que les inscriptions sont ouvertes
à partir de maintenant voilà j'en ai
terminé avec les annonces on va
maintenant pouvoir passer aux réponses à
vos questions donc évidemment je ne
pourrais pas répondre à toutes les
questions qui m'ont été envoyés mais si
vous voulez tenter votre chance la
prochaine fois abonnez vous à ma page
instagram puisque c'est là que
j'annoncerai la prochaine afin qu donc
on y va c'est parti première question
pourquoi le précepteur alors il faut
savoir que initialement la chaîne le
précepteur n'avait pas vocation à être
une chaîne de philosophie mais ça devait
être une chaîne de pédagogie ou à la
limite de philosophie de la connaissance
et c'est suite à de très nombreuses
demandes de votre part de réimporter
mais formats audio mais audio
philosophique depuis mon ancienne chaîne
c'est suite à ses très nombreuses
demandes que la chaîne le précepteur est
devenue une chaîne de philosophie alors
le nom précepteur qui signifie
éducateurs qui signifie instructeur j'ai
choisi ce nom tout simplement parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais encore professeur
particulier et je venais de passer une
formation une formation qui s'intitulait
formation précepteur qui permettait de
valoriser le métier de professeur
particulier puisque c'est un métier qui
n'est pas officiellement reconnue il n'y
a pas de diplôme il n'ya pas d'étude qui
conduisent au métier de professeur
particulier c'est pour ça que très
souvent les parents d'élèves pense que
les professeurs particuliers sont soit
des étudiants soient des professeurs à
la retraite or il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui professeur particulier
c'est un métier à part entière c'est un
métier que l'on peut occuper à plein
temps et donc cette formation précepteur
que j'ai passé elle a pour but de donner
des compétences de donner des
qualifications qu'on acquiert pas
forcément durant nos études etc on
n'acquiert pas non plus forcément par la
seule pratique du métier de professeur
particulier c'est à dire qu'il ya dans
ce métier de précepteur de professeurs
particuliers des composante
psychologique des composantes
pédagogique ce que j'appellerais des
méta compétences c'est-à-dire des
compétences qui ne sont pas directement
liées à la matière qu'on enseigne parce
qu'on peut être très performant dans la
matière qu'on enseigne on peut avoir
énormément de connaissances on pourra
avoir un niveau de spécialisation
extrêmement pointue et pour autant être
une bille en pédagogie c'est à dire que
c'est pas parce qu'on connaît beaucoup
de choses dans un domaine qu'on est apte
à les transmettre qu'on est apte à se
faire comprendre par nos élèves ou qu'on
est apte à gérer les situations
difficiles avec nos élèves ou avec nos
parents d'élèves ont cette formation
précepteur elle m'a été extrêmement
utiles dans l'exercice de mon métier de
professeur particulier et c'est de là
que ma chaîne youtube tire son nom
question suivante quel est ton quotidien
de vidéastes en philosophie alors mon
quotidien de vidéastes il est finalement
assez banal je me lève le matin je
prends un petit déjeuner je vais courir
pendant 45 minutes ensuite je fais une
heure trente à deux heures de sport et
je consacre mon après midi et la soirée
à travailler mon travail il consiste à
lire à écrire
j'écoute beaucoup de vieilles émissions
de radio ou de podcasts de philosophie
donc le plus souvent mes lectures ce
sont des textes que j'ai déjà lu il ya
fort longtemps et que je me remémore que
j'essaie de rafraîchir dans ma mémoire
pour pouvoir préparer l'épisode en cours
ça m'arrive également très fréquemment
de lire de nouveaux textes c'est à dire
d'essayer un petit peu de de renouveler
le champ de la réflexion est donc j'ai
finalement un quotidien assez régulier
assez organisés qui se divise entre
pratique sportive et pratique
philosophique est ce que j'apprécie
beaucoup dans mon quotidien
c'est que finalement même si c'est une
organisation routinière le contenu de
mes journées n'est pas routinier parce
que je ne fais jamais la même chose je
travaille sur des auteurs différents je
travaille sur des époques ou sur des
thématiques différentes ce qui fait que
je suis vacciné contre l'ennui puisque
ne faisant jamais exactement la même
chose ne travaillant jamais sur les
mêmes auteurs ou sur les mêmes
thématiques je n'ai pas cette sensation
d'essoufflement de lassitude ou de
répétition j'ai finalement ce privilège
ni de chiens de l'éternel retour c'est à
dire ce privilège de pouvoir désirer que
la vie que je mène puisse se répéter
indéfiniment question suivante
arrives tu à garder les pieds sur terre
avec le succès que tu rencontres alors
laurent le succès de je rencontre il est
extrêmement relatif je ne suis pas
célèbre au point de me faire harceler
dans la rue ou au point que les gens me
reconnaissent à chaque fois que je vais
faire mes courses ou que j'achète ma
baguette il m'arrive d'être reconnus
peut-être je dirais en moyenne une fois
par mois c'est souvent dans les bars
d'ailleurs que je me fais reconnaître
dans les bars en fin de soirée lorsque
je suis disposé à tout sauf à parler de
philosophie donc garder les pieds sur
terre c'est vraiment pas quelque chose
de difficile pour moi d'autant que quand
je ferme l'ordinateur et que je mets mon
téléphone en silencieux ce qui est le
cas à peu près 23 heures sur 24 eh bien
je ne suis même pas au courant moi même
que je suis youtuber question suivante
quel livre recommanderait tu pour
découvrir la philo à quelqu'un qui n'y
connait rien alors mom in fine que je
vous invite à découvrir sur instagram
j'ai déjà répondu plusieurs fois cette
question et ma réponse c'est que si tu
cherches un premier contact avec la
philosophie mais que tu ne sais pas par
quel livre commence et j'ai créé un
livre spécialement conçu pour les
débutants qui s'appelle tous philosophes
pour une interrogation et que tu
trouveras en libre téléchargement sur
mon site internet le lien est dans la
description question suivante
bonsoir comptez vous faire de nouveaux
entretiens avec des philosophes
contemporains alors oui victor je compte
bien faire des entretiens avec des
philosophes contemporains
je n'en dis pas plus pour l'instant
parce que ça on est encore au stade du
projet ce n'est pas encore totalement
concrétisé et je n'aime pas m'avancer
sur ce qui n'est pas encore fait mais je
peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer que
dans les semaines et les mois qui
arrivent je publierai sur la chaîne des
entretiens avec des philosophes
contemporains question suivante pourquoi
faites-vous de la vulgarisation de
philosophie
pour racheter mes péchés y at il des
podcasts que tu aimerais faire mais la
somme de travail étant trop grande tu
les repousse à chaque fois alors mon
cher jeff on peut dire les choses comme
ça en fait c'est encore plus simple
c'est juste que j'ai une longue liste de
thèmes d'auteur de concepts que
j'aimerais traité sur ma chaîne mais
simplement comme je travaille tout seul
et que je tiens à continuer de
travailler tout seul eh bien je suis
parfois obligés de prioriser je suis
parfois obligé de mettre de côté des
thèmes d'épisodes que je souhaiterais
aborder donc ça m'arrive effectivement
de repousser des sujets de plusieurs
semaines voire de plusieurs mois mais
étant donné que mon travail s'inscrit
dans la durée qui s'inscrit sur du long
terme je ne me sens pas pressurisé je ne
me sens pas dans l'obligation
d'avoir une productivité à tout crin je
prends mon temps est d'ailleurs à chaque
fois que j'annonce que je vais faire une
faq j'ai énormément de personnes qui me
demandent est ce que tu peux parler de
telles hauteurs est ce que tu peux
parler de tels concepts ou de tels
livres sachez que je note toutes vos
suggestions mais que pour certains
sujets il va falloir faire preuve de
patience question suivante
la philosophie est elle plutôt
scientifique ou littéraire c'est une
très bonne question d'autant que
intuitivement on pourrait croire que la
philosophie est une discipline
littéraire alors qu'en réalité elle
n'est pas plus littéraire que
scientifique ou en tout cas la
philosophie est une discipline
d'apparence littéraire mais
méthodologiquement scientifique sert que
pour faire de la philosophie il suffit
pas de gratter du papier en ôtant tout
ce qui nous passe par la tête faire de
la philosophie ça suppose une rigueur
méthodologique ça suppose d'articuler
des idées entre elles selon des
relations logiques c'est d'ailleurs le
principe de la dissertation de philo si
tu es antithèse synthèse c'est à dire
qu'une réflexion il faut qu'elles soient
organisées structurées une réflexion
totalement décousu dans laquelle on se
contente simplement
d'aligner des intuitions ou d'aligner
des aphorismes totalement délier les uns
des autres ça ne produit pas une pensée
ça peut produire de bonnes idées ça peut
produire des petites phrases extrêmement
pénétrant tous extrêmement profonde mais
ça ne produit pas ce qu'on appelle une
pensée philosophique
la différence avec la science c'est que
en philosophie les liens logiques entre
les idées ne sont pas forcément
explicite ne sont pas forcément apparent
et que c'est aussi ça le travail du
philosophe que d'être un narrateur
intellectuelle c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui va proposer un fil conducteur de la
pensée qui ne sera pas forcément
visibles et c'est le fait que la
structure logique d'une pensée
philosophique ne soit pas forcément
explicite qui peut donner l'impression
que c'est une discipline littéraire
alors qu'à mon sens c'est une discipline
qui se situe à l'intersection entre la
science et la littérature aristote
disait que la philosophie était la mère
de toutes les sciences la mère de tous
les savoirs alors c'est une définition
un petit peu prétentieuse de la
philosophie la mère de toutes les
sciences mais je partage la prétention
d'aristote qui est de considérer que la
philosophie a le devoir de prendre de la
hauteur ou en tout cas de prendre du
recul par rapport aux autres disciplines
par rapport aux autres domaines de la
connaissance question suivante selon toi
combien de fois faut-il lire un texte
afin de l'avoir vraiment lui alors merci
pour ta question anthony nos qui est une
question très intéressante
justement parce que souvent on a
l'impression que lire un texte une fois
ça suffit pour dire qu'on le connaît où
ça suffit pour dire qu'on l'aurait
compris non il ne suffit pas d'avoir lu
un texte philosophique une fois pour
l'avoir lu il ne suffit pas l'avoir lu
une fois pour l'avoir compris tout
simplement parce que quand on lit un
texte philosophique on lit ce qu'un
auteur a écrit pour tenter de nous
partager sa pensée or la manière dont un
auteur écrit son texte le choix du
vocabulaire l'a construit sont des
phrases
l'utilisation de procédés rhétoriques
tout ça ça va forcément influencé notre
perception et notre interprétation du
texte et donc pour peu que vous ne
sachiez pas selon quelle définition et
dans quel sens tu es l'auteur emplois
tels mots ça va forcément créer des
incompréhensions parce qu'on est tous
habitués à la définition d'un mot selon
l' usage courant mais on n'est pas
forcément habitué à la définition d'un
mot selon l' usage de telles hauteurs
donc quand nietzsche par exemple parle
du nihilisme
il ne parle pas du nihilisme selon la
définition du dictionnaire il ne parle
pas du ni-ni sme comme d'une attitude
qui consiste à rejeter toute croyance au
contraire pour nietzsche le nihilisme
c'est justement le fait de s'accrocher à
des croyances métaphysique à des
illusions métaphysique qui ne repose sur
rien donc si vous lisez un livre de
nietzsche en croyant connaître la
définition du mot nihilisme parce que
vous l'avez lu dans un dictionnaire ou
parce que vous l'avez lu sur wikipédia
sachez vous n'êtes pas prêts à
comprendre nietzsche parce qu'à l'époque
de nietzsche savait pas wikipedia et que
le sens d'un mot n'était pas simplement
le sens que l'on trouve dans le
dictionnaire et ça c'est uniquement pour
la question du vocabulaire mais à la
limite on pourrait dire on va très bien
une fois qu'on a compris le sens d'un
mot pour telle hauteur on peut
comprendre son texte oui sauf qu'il ya
d'autres problèmes il ya le problème de
la police stratification d'un texte la
police tu rates ification d'un texte ça
veut dire que lorsque vous lisez un
texte et que vous croyez en avoir
compris le sens bien en fait vous n'avez
pas vu qu'il y avait d'autres sens
derrière ce sens initial et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on retrouve beaucoup
chez les auteurs de l'antiquité par
exemple chez platon ou quand vous allez
lire
l'allégorie de la caverne bien vous
allez avoir plusieurs strates plusieurs
couches de signification et donc si vous
avez une lecture ultra littéraliste de
l'allégorie de la caverne ben vous
n'allez pas comprendre le sens de
l'allégorie de la caverne et ça c'est
pas quelque chose que vous allez pouvoir
résoudre en relisant simplement votre
texte une fois ou deux c'est quelque
chose qui va travailler à l'intérieur de
vous pendant des mois pendant des années
et un jour vous allez reprendre ce texte
et vous allez vous dire je comprends
qu'il y a dans ce texte quelque chose
que je n'avais pas perçu je comprends
qu'il ya une strate de signification
qu'il ya une deux sens kim était jusqu
alors resté invisible et c'est ça qui
fait que la philosophie c'est une
herméneutique c'est à dire une science
de l'interprétation et l'interprétation
ce n'est pas quelque chose de subjectif
l'interprétation repose sur des éléments
objectifs mais ça suppose un travail de
la subjectivité pour faire en sorte que
ce qui a un sens d'un point de vue
littérale acquiert un sens d'un point de
vue symbolique voilà concept répond aux
questions suivantes se consacrer à la
philosophie quand on est jeune est ce
une mauvaise idée non c'était pas une
mauvaise idée au contraire je fais
partie de ceux qui prônent
l'enseignement de la philosophie dès
l'école primaire en revanche il est vrai
que lorsqu'on est jeune on n'est pas
forcément dans les meilleures
dispositions pour faire de la
philosophie parce que la philosophie ça
reste une discipline liée à
l'abstraction abstraction au sens
étymologique de ce conte abstrait de ce
qu'on extrait des choses et le plus
souvent l'esprit humain est disposé à
l'abstraction à partir d'un certain âge
à partir d'une certaine expérience c'est
à dire que si on suit un peu l'évolution
de l'esprit depuis l'enfance jusqu'à
l'âge adulte on s'aperçoit qu'au départ
l'enfant est très porté sur la
connaissance sensorielle c'est pour ça
que si vous avez des enfants autour de
vous vous apercevez qu'ils aiment bien
touchés qu'ils aiment bien regarder
qu'ils aiment bien jeter des objets par
terre pour voir le son que ça produit un
enfant qui touche à plein d'objets qui
les jettent ou qui les lance contre le
mur c'est un enfant qui expérimentent
les propriétés sensible des objets
autour de lui ensuite lorsque l'enfant
grandit qu'il arrive à l'adolescence il
va développer une sensibilité
il va développer des as fait on entre
alors dans la connaissance émotionnel et
les problématiques des adolescents
d'ailleurs sont souvent des
problématiques de nature affective de
nature sentimentale et c'est seulement
une fois qu'on arrive à l'âge adulte
qu'on a accumulé suffisamment
d'expérience pour pouvoir en tirer des
enseignements par la méthode de
l'induction et la généralisation qu'à ce
moment là l'esprit est prêt à manipuler
des abstractions c'est-à-dire à
manipuler des concepts et donc je
comprends très bien qu'un adolescent
lorsqu'il entre en terminale et pas
forcément un un grand engouement pour la
philosophie qui se disent que ça n'a pas
d'utilité parce que tout simplement ça
ne répond pas à ces problématiques
d'adolescents donc je ne dirais pas que
c'est une mauvaise idée de se consacrer
à la philosophie quand on est jeune au
contraire en revanche je pense que c'est
une mauvaise idée de vouloir forcer de
vouloir obliger des jeunes à
s'intéresser à la philosophie si l'heure
n'est pas encore venue pour eux
question suivante comment es tu es tu au
lycée alors au lycée j'ai été un petit
con et un petit con prétentieux
c'est à dire que j'étais persuadé d'être
plus intelligent que tout le monde je me
croyais un peu plus malin que les autres
et j'avais le désir de le montrer un
petit peu comme will hunting le
personnage joué par matt damon dans le
film avec robin williams et d'ailleurs
je me souviens que mon premier devoir de
philosophie que j'ai rendu à l'époque
porté sur la question peut-on définir
l'homme par la conscience et je m'étais
amusé pendant toute une partie de ma
dissertation a expliqué qu' on ne
pouvait pas définir l'homme qu'on ne
pouvait pas le définir par quoi que ce
soit précisément parce que la nature de
l'homme c'est d'être en constante
évolution et de ne jamais être identique
à soi même et donc la conclusion de ma
dissertation c'était de dire puisqu'on
ne peut pas définir l'homme et puis on
ne peut pas le définir par la conscience
ça m'avait valu une note assez correct
mais je me souviens du commentaire que
m'avait laissé mon prof de philosophie
m'avait dit la modestie sied au
philosophe donc c'était une manière
assez diplomatique de me traiter de
petit con prétentieux il avait raison et
cet épisode de ma vie me rappelle à quel
point moins on en sait et plus on croit
en savoir question suivante quel est
l'événement la pensée ou l'idée qui t'a
amené vers la philosophie est à pousser
à l'enseigné il n'y a pas vraiment
d'événements à proprement parler on va
dire que lorsque je suis rentrée en
terminale et que j'ai commencé la
philosophie je savais avant même de
commencer que c'était une discipline qui
allait me plaire qui allaient
m'intéressait parce que je faisais
partie car justement de cette rare
catégorie d'adolescents
qui s'intéressait beaucoup aux idées au
concept même si j'avais une approche
pour le moins approximative des concepts
à l'époque par contre je me souviens
très nettement que déjà à 16 ou 17 ans
j'étais convaincu que la dualité entre
raison et passion n'était pas une vraie
dualité ou plutôt que tout ce que l'on
croît être motivé par la raison les
temps réalité par la passion ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que le choix de
la raison relève d'une motivation qui
n'est pas la raison elle-même qu'est ce
qui fait que vous allez préférer la
raison à la passion c'est une passion
c'est la passion qui vous conduit à
préférer la raison parce que c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas de l'ordre
du démontrable ou de l'expliqua bhl qui
vous fait préférer la raison et ça c'est
une idée que j'ai eue quand j'étais
adolescent que je croyais être une idée
absolument révolutionnaire qui allait
complètement bouleversé la face du monde
et c'est quelque chose qui continue
encore aujourd'hui
d'alimenter ma réflexion parce que dès
que j'entends quelqu'un me dire qu'il
est totalement détaché de ses affects et
qu'ils voient les choses de manière
rationnelle et objective je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de me dire que cette personne
est sous l'emprise d'une croyance est
sous l'emprise d'un désir de croire
qu'elle peut se détacher de ses affects
et de ses émotions pour accéder un point
de vue omniscient nous sommes tous des
points de vue sur le monde on ne peut
pas atteindre la neutralité on peut pas
atteindre l'objectivité en revanche on
peut essayer d'être honnête et essayer
d'être honnête ça veut dire comprendre
que notre point de vue n'est qu'un point
de vue parmi d'autres et que toute
personne a de bonnes raisons de croire
ce qu'elle croit à chaque fois que vous
pensez qu'une personne à de mauvaises
raisons de croire ce qu'elle croit sais
que c'est vous qui est dans
l'incompréhension des ressorts véritable
de la croyance la croyance c'est le
fruit d'une expérience de vie
c'est le fruit d'un historique de causes
et d'effets qui nous a conduit à croire
ce que l'on croit et à ne pas pouvoir
être convaincu du contraire en trois
lignes vous ne convaincrez jamais
quelqu'un que ce qu'il a mis 20 ans 30
ans ou 40 ans à penser est faux vous ne
pourrez pas le convaincre tout au plus
pourrait vous l'encourager à envisager
d'autres points de vue et c'est déjà
beaucoup et c'est déjà phénoménal parce
que si vous regardez bien c'est
extrêmement rare que l'on se demande
pourquoi cette personne pense qu'elles
pensent la plupart du temps on se
demande qu'est ce que je pourrais dire à
cette personne pour lui prouver qu'elle
a tort sous-entendu qu'est ce que je
pourrais lui dire pour lui prouver que
c'est moi qui ai raison donc c'est
souvent par ego que l'on cherche à
démontrer qu'on a raison à l'autre c'est
à dire qu'à un moment donné on se croit
investi d'une mission métaphysique on va
enfiler sa cape de justicier de la
vérité on se sent appartenir à la
brigade de la vérité à la patrouille de
l'exactitude et on intervient sur les
lieux du crime les lieux de
l'irrationnel les lieux de la croyance
les lieux de la superstition ou de la
fée de news pour rétablir la vérité pour
planter le drapeau de la vérité tout ça
me semble extrêmement problématique
parce qu'à aucun moment on ne cherche à
comprendre pourquoi l'autre pense ce
qu'il pense on considère la conscience
de l'autre comme une conscience a servi
comme une conscience aliéné sans se
poser la question de son propre
asservissement et de sa propre
aliénation et ça personnellement je
trouve que c'est quelque chose de très
délétère pour la pensée philosophique
question suivante d'où vient cet amour
de la philosophie
du ciel des idées doit-on toujours
remettre en cause nos idées
philosophiques
je dirais que si ton objectif est
d'accéder à ce que les philosophes
appellent la vérité tu ne peux pas y
échapper tu es obligé de remettre
toujours en cause ce que tu crois être
vrai et sauf qu'au bout d'un moment il
faut bien avancer on peut pas toujours
stagné on peut pas toujours faire du
surplace au niveau de sa réflexion
philosophique il faut avancer et donc
pour avancer il faut bien un moment
donné considérer les choses comme
acquise on ne peut pas fonctionner
indéfiniment sur deûle instable et du
précaire et là on en revient à ce que je
disais précédemment c'est à dire que le
meilleur moyen d'avancer dans sa
connaissance ou dans sa réflexion
philosophique c'est de considérer chaque
contradictions où chaque désaccord comme
une occasion d'envisager les choses du
point de vue de l'autre du point de vue
de la perception et du regard de l'autre
et ça ça veut dire ne pas chercher
forcément a trop la vérité définitive
mais plutôt laissé les choses
travaillaient à l'intérieur de notre
esprit parce que c'est comme ça
finalement que notre réflexion va
évoluer au fil du temps donc j'ai envie
de te dire remet en cause des idées
philosophiques
lorsque l'occasion s'en présente mais ne
remet pas en cause les idées
philosophiques constamment parce que
c'est le meilleur moyen de perdre ou
tout et repère question suivante
pourquoi se dépasser quand on peut se
contenter de ce que l'on a alors oui on
peut voir les choses comme ça se
dépassaient n'est pas une obligation ce
n'était pas un impératif existentielle
mais on peut considérer que se dépasser
c'est aussi le moyen de devenir la
meilleure version de soi même et que
l'un des buts de notre existence
consiste précisément à s'améliorer c'est
à dire à accomplir son essence question
suivante
selon vous notre monde actuel
possède-t-il décante heidegger mozart
balzac et cetera alors la question qui
est posée ici c'est de savoir si il
existe aujourd'hui de grands philosophes
ou de grands artistes tels qu'on a pu en
connaître jusqu'au 19ème siècle je pense
que la réponse est oui même si le
problème c'est toujours celui du recul
le recul par rapport à une production
philosophique ou par rapport à une
production artistique c'est quelque
chose qui nécessite du temps des années
des décennies est très souvent un grand
philosophe ou un grand écrivain ne sera
reconnu comme tel que par la postérité
c'est à dire que plusieurs décennies
plus tard la question qui se pose à mon
avis c'est plutôt de savoir quels sont
les moyens contemporains pour un artiste
ou pour un intellectuel
d'émerger c'est à dire de se faire
connaître du grand public
c'est toujours la question que se pose
un artiste aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
s'il va réussir a rencontré son public
et pour rencontrer son public eh bien il
faut avoir des moyens matériels
d'accéder à la visibilité c'est un peu
le sens de ma réponse a monté de la
chaîne linguistic à et dans l'épisode
que j'ai consacré à la notion de mérite
en disant que le mérite n'était pas
simplement une affaire de talent ce
n'était pas simplement une affaire
d'intelligence c'est aussi mettre en
oeuvre les moyens d'accéder à la
visibilité et ces moyens là sont parfois
totalement 1 et pendant du talent lui
même un grand intellectuel un grand
philosophe un grand artiste ne sera
jamais reconnue au sens littéral on ne
le reconnaîtra jamais puisqu'il n'aura
pas accédé à la célébrité s'il ne met
pas en place des moyens de se faire
connaître ça peut paraître une évidence
ça peut paraître une banalité mais c'est
une manne alité qui méritent d'être
rappelés parce qu'on a souvent tendance
aujourd'hui à considérer que pour
accéder à la reconnaissance il suffirait
d'avoir du talent il suffirait d'être
quelqu'un qui a des compétences hors du
commun alors que non le talent n'est
qu'un des nombreux paramètres n'est
qu'une des nombreuses variables qui
entre en compte dans l'axé à la
reconnaissance question suivante tu
conseilles des exercices pour
s'entraîner à articuler sa pensée alors
le meilleur exercice que je peux
recommander pour articuler sa pensée
c'est de la poser sur papier sous forme
de plan pas de la rédiger mais
simplement de faire un plan pour
s'habituer à structurer ses idées et une
fois que d'autres pensé et structuré une
fois qu'elle est organisée en étape il
devient beaucoup plus facile non
seulement de la restituer c'est à dire
de l'exposer aux autres mais aussi de la
perfectionner de l'améliorer en
permanence et c'est pour ça que je dis
souvent que la pensée c'est une forme
d'architecturé parce que les idées
s'agencent se combinent elles se
soutiennent les unes les autres et le
fait de les poser sur papier sous une
forme très synthétique sous une forme
très ramassée c'est ça qui va permettre
ensuite de mieux maîtriser cette pensée
et de pouvoir l'a complétée de pouvoir
la prolonger et donc c'est ça finalement
qui va te permettre de mieux penser
parce que la pensée se développe
d'autant mieux qu'elle est structuré
question suivante comment trouves-tu le
temps de travailler ton corps et ton
esprit tout en sachant que la plupart
des gens disent que cela n'est pas
possible là ma réponse elle tient dans
un seul mot que j'ai prononcé plusieurs
fois dans ma réponse précédente
c'est l'organisation oui plusieurs
personnes pensent que ce n'est pas
possible de à la fois faire du sport
lire écrire sortir avec ses amis je
considère pour ma part que lorsqu'on a
une bonne organisation c'est à dire tout
simplement lorsqu'on considère que le
temps est précieux et qu'on ne le
dépensent pas pour des choses inutiles
il est possible de faire beaucoup de
choses alors on ne peut pas tout faire
une seule vie ne suffit pas pour avoir
plusieurs vies mais par contre il est
possible d'optimiser son temps de ne pas
le laisser s'échapper et le meilleur
moyen pour ça c'est d'organiser son
emploi du temps son usage du temps et
surtout de s'y tenir
c'est à dire de se donner une discipline
au quotidien de se donner de bonnes
habitudes des habitudes qui font que ce
rythme qu'on va se donner ce rythme
organisé ne sera plus du tout perçue
comme une contrainte mais au contraire
ce sera perçu comme quelque chose qui va
de soi et qui nous donne envie de
maintenir cette organisation question
suivante que pensez-vous des sports de
combat comme la boxe
la boxe c'est la vie la boxe c'est le
sport par excellence c'est le noble art
le sport qui nous confronte à l'autre le
sport qui nous confronte à nous mêmes
qui jouent à la fois sur la dimension
physique et sur la dimension mentale la
boxe est un sport que j'ai pratiqué
pendant plusieurs années donc forcément
je ne suis pas objectif dans ma réponse
mais je considère et j'ai souvent eu
l'occasion de le dire que le travail du
corps que l'activité du corps n'est non
seulement pas incompatibles avec
l'activité de l'esprit n'est pas
incompatible avec la philosophie mais
qu'au contraire elle la complète parce
que l'avis du cor influence voire
déterminent la vie de l'esprit et l'idée
qu'il faudrait opposé la vie de l'esprit
et la vie du corps me semble non
seulement une idée fausse mais ça me
semble surtout une idée qui est là pour
justifier l'absence d'activité du corps
pour des personnes qui ne sont pas à
l'aise dans ce domaine là on est encore
héritiers de ce dualisme mal digéré
entre le corps et l'esprit un dualisme
qui nous fait croire que si on est dans
le monde des idées on n'est pas dans le
monde du corps et si on est dans le
monde du corps on n'est pas dans le
monde des idées je pense que c'est une
idée qui dissimule un mépris du corps je
pense que c'est une idée qui dissimule
une inaptitude à l'activité physique et
que c'est toujours plus pratique que
c'est toujours plus facile de mépriser
l'activité physique plutôt que de la
pratique est question suivante combien
de la sonde anton pastis 2 est il
nécessaire de faire le deuil de
l'obligation pour être libre
alors j'aime beaucoup la formulation de
ta question je trouve que c'est une
belle manière de le dire
en fait il faut distinguer deux temps
dans la réflexion la liberté dans son
sens le plus courant dans son sens
littéral c'est effectivement le fait de
ne pas être contraint le fait de ne pas
être forcées ou obligé donc de ce point
de vue là il est vrai que faire le deuil
de l'obligation c'est une belle manière
de définir la liberté remarquerez
souvent d'ailleurs que ce qui nous
empêche d'être libre c'est moins ce que
le monde nous empêche de faire que ce
que l'on sent pêche soi même de faire
parce qu'on a des croyances des
croyances auto limitantes parce qu'on a
un sur moi c'est à dire une sorte de
gendarme intérieur qui nous surveillent
qui nous sanctionne qui nous punit si on
ne fait pas ce qu'il faut faire donc ça
c'est l'origine de la culpabilité la
culpabilité c'est le fait de se punir
donc de s'infliger soi même une
souffrance un châtiment parce qu'on
estime qu'on n'a pas rempli nos
obligations et vous remarquerez que très
souvent on ne se pose même pas la
question de savoir mais qu'est ce qu'il
se produirait si je sais c'est d'obéir à
telle ou telle obligation alors que la
réponse c il se produirait rien très
souvent ne pas obéir à des obligations à
des obligations réelles ou des
obligations supposer c'est à dire des
obligations mental en réalité ça n'a
strictement aucun impact dans notre vie
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que on
est souvent prisonniers de la perception
qu'on a de l'obligation davantage que
des conséquences réelles de l'obligation
et c'est ça qui fait que parfois on ne
va pas s'autoriser à faire des choses on
va s'interdire de faire des choses parce
qu'on associe ça dans notre esprit à
quelque chose de mal c'est à dire dans
les faits à quelque chose de
culpabiliser ont donc être capable de
faire le deuil de ses propres
obligations peut être un excellent moyen
en effet d'accéder à la liberté
maintenant le deuxième temps de la
réponse c'est de dire que la liberté ce
n'est pas seulement l'absence de
contrainte puisque de toute façon en
tant qu'être humain c'est-à-dire en tant
qu'être physique nous sommes soumis à
des lois nous sommes soumis à des
contraintes et donc il n'est pas
question de dire que l'on pourrait
échapper à toute forme de contrainte
l'idée c'est de dire que la liberté peut
résider dans le choix de ses contraintes
c'est à dire dans le fait de se donner
des objectifs dans le fait de se donner
des projets et que réaliser ses
objectifs et ses projets ça suppose une
discipline ça suppose des contraintes
mais ces contraintes on peut y obéir
librement on peut même s'y soumettre
librement et c'est un exemple que
j'avais donnés en parlant du sportif qui
obéit à son coach un sportif qui obéit à
son coach n'obéit pas à son coach il
obéit aux savoirs de son coach autrement
dit il se soumet librement à un
enseignement qui sait être bénéfique
pour lui parce qu'il correspond aux
moyens d'atteindre ses objectifs
on trouverait ça complètement absurde de
dire qu'un sportif qui obéit à son
entraîneur n'est pas libre la réalité
c'est que le sportif qui va atteindre un
objectif va mettre en place des moyens
d'accéder à cet objectif et que pour y
accéder il est obligé de se soumettre un
certain nombre de contraintes donc c'est
comme ça pour ma part que j'appréhende
la notion de liberté non pas l'absence
de contraintes non pas à la
désobéissance à toute forme de
contrainte mais le choix de ces
contraintes dans le but d'atteindre un
objectif question suivante
plutôt camus ou sartre camus comment
fais tu pour qu'aucun événement externe
n'affecte tombe bien être alors
stéphanie je ne sais pas à quelle
occasion j'ai pu dire ou même laisser
penser que je n'étais pas affecté par
les événements externes tout simplement
parce que ce n'est pas le cas 1 je suis
un être humain comme les autres et donc
je suis bien entendu affectée par
certains événements externes la question
serait plutôt de savoir comment je fais
pour que la manière dont je suis affecté
par les événements externes ne m'empêche
pas de vivre et ça c'est quelque chose
de très différent parce qu'en réalité on
peut accepter d'être affecté par les
événements on peut accepter l'émotion
mais ça ne veut pas dire que l'on se
place sous le contrôle de notre émotion
ça ne veut pas dire que l'on devient
l'esclave de nos émotions et ça
effectivement c'est quelque chose que
j'essaie d'éviter d'être l'esclave de
mes émotions mais en réalité ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui relève du choix
c'est pas quelque chose qui relève du
décret on ne décide pas de ne pas être
affectée par ses émotions on l'est où on
ne l'est pas et généralement c'est
plutôt notre expérience de vie c'est
plutôt l'endurance acquise grâce à
l'expérience de la vie qui fait qu'on va
être plus ou moins sous l'emprise de ses
émotions est la meilleure illustration
de ce phénomène c'est que lorsque vous
étiez enfant ou lorsque vous étiez
adolescent vous étiez affecté par les
choses qui ne vous affecterait plus
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on est adolescent une
déception amoureuse c'est la fin du
monde une dispute avec un ami c'est la
fin du monde mais lorsqu'on devient
adulte lorsqu'on a expérimenté les
déceptions amoureuses les disputes avec
les amis les erreurs et les échecs
finalement on a une tendance naturelle à
relativiser les choses c'est à dire à
davantage les accepte et à ne pas les
dramatiser à ne pas en faire de
mélodrame parce qu'on sait qu'on y
survivra parce qu'on sait que notre vie
ne s'arrête pas là parce qu'on sait
qu'on en verra d'autres et parce qu'on
sait que si on devait s'arrêter à ça et
se laisser atteindre par tous les
désagréments qui constitue notre
existence bien finalement on se
condamnerait soi-même au malheur
question suivante y at il des
philosophes avec lesquels vous n'êtes
pas du tout d'accord oui il y à des
philosophes avec lesquels je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord il ya même des
philosophes dont j'ai parlé sur ma
chaîne avec lesquels je ne suis pas du
tout d'accord mais en réalité dans ce
pas du tout d'accord il y a une petite
exagération
parce qu'en réalité dire qu'on n'est pas
du tout d'accord
c'est une caricature on n'est jamais pas
du tout d'accord on est toujours plus ou
moins pas d'accord donc là encore c'est
quelque chose de relatif il ya des
philosophes avec lesquels je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord dont j'ai parlé sur ma
chaîne précisément parce que je trouve
intéressant l'exercice qui consiste à se
glisser dans la conscience de l'autre
pour tenter de comprendre comment il
perçoit le monde pour tenter de
comprendre quelles sont les raisons qui
l'a de penser ce qu'il pense et qu'un
certain niveau la quête de la vérité
elle passe nécessairement par cet
exercice le transfert de conscience de
transferts de perception qui consiste à
se demander à travers quelle grille de
lecture l'autre voit-il le monde et
personnellement c'est ça qui m'intéresse
dire que si je ne devais parler que de
choses avec lesquelles je suis d'accord
j'aurais l'impression de marcher sur un
tapis roulant j'aurais l'impression
d'être un hamster qui se donnent
l'illusion d'avancer alors qu'il tourne
en rond donc il y à des philosophes dont
j'ai parlé sur ma chaîne avec lesquels
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord et
d'ailleurs je vous mets au défi de
trouver les noms des philosophes avec
lesquels je ne suis pas d'accord et dont
j'ai parlé pour voir si c'est quelque
chose de perceptible pour voir si malgré
moi mon désaccord avec ces philosophes
transparaît ce sera un exercice
intéressant donc j'attends vos réponses
dans les commentaires avec quel
philosophe est ce que je ne suis pas du
tout d'accord
question suivante
je remarquais que tu parles beaucoup de
physique et de science ça t'intéresse
aussi alors c'est intéressant parce que
je n'ai pas l'impression de parler
énormément de sciences sur la chaîne
mais c'est quelque chose qui doit
transparaître malgré moi parce qu'il est
vrai que j'ai beaucoup d'intérêt pour
les questions scientifiques pour les
questions liées à la physique à la
biologie ou même à l'astronomie parce
que je n'aime pas du tout que l'on parle
d'un domaine sur lequel on n'est pas
compétent en affichant des prétentions
en affichant des qualifications que l'on
n'a pas et je me garderai bien de donner
mon avis sur des questions scientifiques
sur lesquelles je n'ai travaillé que de
manière superficielle ou sur lesquels
mes connaissances sont en réalité des
intuitions question suivante
votre profession est un moyen comme un
autre de vivre de la philo ou bien une
véritable passion alors mon cher ludo je
ne sais pas quelle profession tu exerces
mais lorsqu'on est professeur professeur
de philosophie en l'occurrence ça me
semble extrêmement compliqué d'en faire
son métier sans que ça ne soit d'une
manière ou d'une autre une passion et a
fortiori lorsqu'on choisit de faire de
l'enseignement une activité sur youtube
une activité publique sur internet je
suis mon propre patron et donc si je
n'ai pas cette flamme de la passion si
je n'ai pas ce réservoir de motivation
interne qui est ma passion pour la
philosophie
bien je pense que j'aurai raccroché les
gants depuis longtemps donc une manière
comme une autre de vivre de la philo ça
me paraît être une perception un petit
peu étrange des choses une perception en
tout cas qui n'est pas la mienne
question suivante
selon toi quels seront les nouveaux
thèmes de philosophie à l'avenir je
dirais la question du transhumanisme la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
la question de l'homme augmenté c'est à
dire de toutes les avancées
technologiques qui vont produire des
modifications de ce que nos aïeux aurait
appelé l'essence de l'homme on dit
souvent que l'essence de l'homme ce sont
ses capacités spirituelles c'est la vie
spirituelle qui fait que l'homme est un
animal un peu à part philosophiquement
parlant le transhumanisme ça nous pose
une question qui est de savoir est ce
qu'il est dans la nature de l'homme de
dépasser le stade de l'homme est ce que
le fait de dépasser nos capacités innées
nos capacités naturelles est-ce que ça
ça fait partie de notre essence certains
répondront que oui que depuis
l'émergence de l'humanité l'homme n'a
cessé de s'auto dépassé l'homme n'a
cessé de transcender ses propres limites
et donc ils diront que finalement le
projet transhumanistes n'est rien
d'autre que le prolongement n'est rien
d'autre que le développement de cette
ambition originel de l'être humain qui
est de dépasser en permanence sa propre
nature tandis que d'autres vont
considérer que le transhumanisme en tant
que projet de modification de notre
substance physique c'est quelque chose
qui sort totalement de ce qu'on avait vu
par le passé c'est quelque chose qui
excède en nature toutes les évolutions
que l'être humain a connu depuis la
préhistoire je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent qu'il est dans l'essence de
l'homme de transcender constamment ses
propres limites en revanche je considère
qu'il y a dans le projet transhumanistes
d'augmentation technologique des
capacités humaines quelque chose qui va
soulever des problématiques d'ordre
éthique quelque chose qui peut même
s'accompagner de certaines dérives
dérive éthique et politique et je prends
vraiment mes distances par rapport
un certain enthousiasme transhumanistes
qui existe de nos jours et qui me semble
parfaitement aveugle aux conséquences et
aux implications éthiques d'un tel
projet question suivante quelles sont
les limites de la philosophie la
philosophie ne pourra pas faire en sorte
que vous ayez de la volonté pour
concrétiser ce que vous croyez être vrai
la philosophie agit sur la pensée mais
elle n'agit pas sur la volonté qui anime
une pensée et c'est là où à mon avis
réside un grand malentendu qui est de
confondre la pensée et la volonté qui
anime la pensée une pensée qui n'est pas
animé par une volonté est une pensée
stérile et c'est pas grave d'avoir
dépensé stérile parce qu'après tout on
n'a pas signé un contrat de productivité
en venant au monde mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que la pensée qui n'est pas
accompagnée des moyens de concrétiser
cette pensée elle ne produit rien est
quelqu'un qui a une pensée pauvres mais
qui valent à concrétiser aura toujours
plus d' influence dans le monde que
quelqu'un qui a de grandes idées mais
qui ne va pas à les concrétiser donc les
limites de la philosophie selon - elles
sont là la philosophie nous aident à
penser mais elle ne nous aide pas à
concrétiser notre pensée question
suivante pensez vous que vos vidéos
suffisent à comprendre les pensée des
philosophes dont vous avez déjà traités
dans vos vidéos non mais épisode ne
remplace pas la lecture des oeuvres des
philosophes dont je parle
mais épisodes sont des introductions
sont des initiations j'oserais dire d
invitation à découvrir la pensée de
l'auteur et la pensée de l'auteur elle
se découvre à travers ses oeuvres
n'a pas l'impression de trop vulgariser
l'ensemble des sujets que tu abordes
est-ce que youtube est le meilleur
format pour la philosophie alors youtube
est évidemment un format limité pour
parler de philosophie cela étant je n'ai
vraiment pas l'impression de trop
vulgariser si j'en crois la plupart des
commentaires j'ai plutôt l'impression
que c'est le contraire il ya certains de
mes épisodes sur lesquels faut
s'accrocher l'idée qui revient c'est que
certains des épisodes doivent être
réécoutée plusieurs fois j'ai même
certains auditeurs qui me disent qu'ils
prennent des notes justement parce que
le contenu est assez dense est assez
riche
trouvez que mes épisodes sont trop
vulgariser c'est peut-être avoir une
vision un peu biaisée de ce que c'est
que la vulgarisation c'est peut-être
confondre la vulgarisation et
l'enseignement universitaire et
d'ailleurs si tu écoutes bien mais
épisode tu verras que je ne suis pas
avare en mots techniques en jargon
technique mais simplement j'essaye
d'illustrer ces mots techniques par des
exemples et j'essaye de proposer un fil
conducteur de la pensée qui fait qu'on
ne se sent pas perdu et si tu me dis que
tu as l'impression que mes épisodes sont
trop vulgariser la finalement c'est
peut-être un compliment que tu es en
train de me faire parce que ça signifie
que tu arrives à comprendre tout ce que
je dis et quand ça paraît simple ça veut
dire que c'est bien fait un travail bien
fait c'est un travail dans lequel on ne
voit pas les traces du travail lorsque
tu vois les traces de peinture au
rouleau lorsque tu visait un appartement
ça signifie que le peintre a mal fait
son travail parce qu'il a laissé des
traces de son travail donc pour répondre
à ta question je n'ai vraiment pas
l'impression de trop vulgariser les
sujets dont je parle sur ma chaîne j'ai
plutôt l'impression et même si ça peut
paraître très modeste que ma chaîne fait
partie des chaînes qui ne confondent pas
vulgarisation et simplification à
outrance j'ai vraiment l'impression de
ne pas sacrifier l'exigence de rigueur
de précision et de profondeur sur
l'autel de la transmission question
suivante
quel est le livre que tu aurais voulu
écrire
j'aurais voulu écrire la phénoménologie
de l'esprit de hegel
es tu vraiment mon père comme certains
le prétendent
alors le philosophe je ne vois
absolument pas de quoi tu parles par
contre il me fera le plaisir de ranger
ta chambre immédiatement
quels sont à pâtisserie et plats
préférés alors ma pâtisserie préférée ce
sont les profiteroles et mon plat
préféré c'est le lapin à la moutarde
est ce que tu parles autre langue je
suis brésilienne et suis en train
d'apprendre le français avec tes vidéos
et j'aime beaucoup bien non par le
melting ouest l'année
un stream parlando l'italiano bonjour
quelle valeur place tu au dessus des
autres le courage quel est le philosophe
dont il a éprouvé le plus de difficultés
à comprendre les thèses
c'est difficile parce que il ya des
auteurs qui sont difficiles à lire et à
comprendre lors d'une première lecture
et finalement à force de persévérance à
force de se plonger dans les textes ont
fini par comprendre ce qu'ils ont voulu
dire on se rend compte que
l'idée en elle-même n'était pas
extrêmement compliqué c'est plutôt la
forme qu'utilise l'auteur qui étaient
compliqués par contre il ya des auteurs
qui sont faussement simple des auteurs
qui lorsqu'on les lits nous donne
l'impression qu'on a tout compris du
premier coup alors qu'en fait quand on
replonge dans les textes plusieurs
années plus tard et à ce moment là on
s'aperçoit qu'on n'avait pas vraiment ou
saisies ou en tout cas qu'on n'avait pas
compris toutes les couches de
signification platon est un bon exemple
de philosophes qui semble facile à
comprendre de même que des cartes est un
exemple de philosophes qui semble facile
à comprendre et qui sont en réalité
beaucoup plus profond est beaucoup plus
utile qu'une première lecture ne
pourrait le laisser penser revanche il
ya des auteurs comme spinoza comme quand
tout comme eagle dont la lecture
refroidi dans la lecture impressionne
dont même parfois la lecture des courage
parce qu'ils s'expriment dans un jargon
extrêmement compliqué kant et hegel sont
vraiment les spécialistes de la pensée
formellement compliqué mais lorsqu'on
arrive à aller outre cette barrière
linguistique et cette barrière
syntaxiques on s'aperçoit finalement que
les idées qui sont développés sont
relativement intuitive et donc à ce
moment là on s'aperçoit que la
difficulté tient moins à la complexité
des concepts qu'à la complexité de la
langue qui est utilisé pour traduire ses
concepts salut charles j'aimerais savoir
ce qui nous a déjà menti dans les
anciennes faq alors menti non je n'ai
pas le souvenir d'avoir menti lors de
mes précédentes faq en revanche ce qui
est possible c'est que sur certains
sujets je me sois trompé
ce qui est également possible c'est que
mon opinion et évoluer et là j'ai un
souvenir qui me revient où j'avais dit à
propos d'une question qu'on m'avait posé
sur monsieur fille et le travail de
monsieur fille et je me souviens qu'à
l'époque j'avais répondu que si monsieur
fille me proposer de faire une
collaboration avec lui j'accepterai avec
plaisir parce que j'appréciais beaucoup
son travail c'est vrai que j'apprécie
beaucoup le travail de monsieur fille
mais entre temps mon opinion a évolué
sur l'opportunité d'une collaboration
entre lui et moi tout simplement parce
que je pense que nos approches sont non
seulement très différentes mais
peut-être même incompatible j'ai
peut-être été un peu complaisant dans ma
réponse parce que j'estime que toute
personne qui produit un travail de
transmission culturelle sur internet
fait quelque chose de positif pour le
groupe et pour l'humanité avec le recul
je me dis aujourd'hui qu'il est déjà
fort peu probable que cette
collaboration et lieu compte tenu
notamment de l'écart et de la divergence
de nos approches de la philosophie j'ai
parfois l'impression que dans la manière
de transmettre des connaissances
philosophiques
monsieur fille inclut un certain nombre
de croyances personnelles un certain
nombre de biais cognitifs et donc pour
ces raisons je pense qu'il y a peu de
chances qu'une collaboration puisse
avoir lieu entre monsieur fille et moi
et enfin la dernière question salut
charles as tu des questions à poser
attaque communauté alors je n'ai pas de
questions à poser à ma communauté en
revanche j'ai un message à faire passer
à ma communauté le message est le
suivant si aujourd'hui vous appréciez le
contenu que je propose sur ma chaîne si
aujourd'hui vous êtes content quand vous
recevez une notification
qui vous avertit que je viens de sortir
un nouvel épisode
j'ai envie de vous dire profitez en bien
profitez-en bien parce que ça ne va pas
durer éternellement pourquoi je dis ça
parce que qu'on le veuille ou non tout
ce qu'on apprécie un moment donné on
finit par le déprécier tout ce qui nous
procure de la joie du plaisir de la
satisfaction on finit par s'y habituer
et au bout d'un certain temps d'habitude
on finit par percevoir et par être
sensible à ce qui ne nous plaît pas
lorsqu'on aime quelque chose arrive
toujours un moment où on finit par des
haies mais d aimer ne veut pas dire
détesté ça ne veut pas dire haïr ça veut
simplement dire qu'on passe à autre
chose ça veut simplement dire on a fait
le tour et c'est normal c'est tout à
fait normal à un moment donné de moins
aimé quelque chose qui nous a procuré
beaucoup de plaisir où beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé est ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que lorsque viendra le jour
où vous n'éprouvez plus en écoutant les
épisodes le plaisir que vous éprouviez
au début n'hésitez pas à faire une pause
n'hésitez pas à arrêter de m'écouter
n'hésitez pas à aller voir ailleurs je
ne suis pas là pour recevoir des
compliments même si les compliments font
toujours plaisir ne soyons pas
hypocrites mais je suis là comme on
l'est tous pour accompagner un moment de
votre vie toutes les personnes que vous
avez côtoyé dans votre vie vous ont
accompagnés pendant un moment de votre
vie certains de ces personnes vous ont
aidé à franchir une étape certaines de
ces personnes vous ont aidé à prendre
conscience de quelque chose qui vous
aura aidé à avancer mais à moins que
vous ne juriez fidélité à la personne
avec laquelle vous vous engagez n'avait
aucun devoir de continuer à aimer
quelque chose qui ne vous plait plus
donc le jour où vous en aurez marre de
moi jour où vous en aurez marre de
m'écouter disserter pendant 45 minutes
sur un auteur bien ce jour là arrêtez de
m'écouter arrêtez de m'écouter et aller
vers de nouveaux plaisirs et j'ai dit
tout à l'heure en souriant que si je
m'étais lancé dans la vulgarisation de
la philosophie sur youtube c'était pour
rembourser mes péchés il y a un fond de
vérité dans cette réponse qui est que
tout ce qu'on fait on le fait avant tout
pour soi et si on fait les choses pour
soi on doit pas hésiter à arrêter de
faire ce qu'on aime plus et à aller
découvrir aller explorer de nouvelles
choses qui seront nos amours de demain
aujourd'hui ma chaîne a atteint 400
mille abonnés ça fait maintenant plus de
trois ans que je réalise des vidéos de
philosophie et je sais que parmi vous il
y à des personnes qui me suivent et qui
m'écoutent depuis le début ils compris
même depuis mon ancienne chaîne et je
sais aussi que parmi les personnes qui
m'écoutait depuis le début il y en a qui
à un moment donné son parti parce
qu'elle ne trouvait plus dans mon
contenu ce qui les faisait vibrer au
début ces personnes ont eu raison comme
ont raison toutes les personnes qui
considèrent qu évolué c'est aller vers
l'ailleurs
mon but à travers ma chaîne
c'est de poser ma pierre à cet édifice
qu'est le monde
vous avez tous votre pierre à poser
posez votre pierre à l'édifice et ne
vous retournez pas
[Musique]